lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
nos familiaricemos con la idea de la
masa molecular comencemos con una
molécula con la que todos estamos
familiarizados y de hecho tenemos una
gran cantidad de esta molécula en
nuestros cuerpos y esta es agua
la fórmula molecular del agua es h2o
cada molécula de agua tiene dos átomos
de hidrógeno y un átomo de oxígeno lo
que yo tengo curiosidad es conocer la
masa de una molécula de agua la forma en
la que ustedes pueden calcularla o
encontrarla es encontrar la masa de cada
uno de los hidrógenos y después
encontrar la masa del oxígeno vamos a
hacerlo
cuál es la masa del hidrógeno vamos a la
tabla periódica para encontrar la masa
del hidrógeno vemos que el hidrógeno
tiene un número atómico de 1 lo que
significa que es el número de protones
lo cual hace que sea un hidrógeno y aquí
abajo tenemos este número y dice 1.0
07 94 vamos a redondear los 1.000 puntos
79 este es el peso atómico del hidrógeno
si nosotros tomáramos los diferentes
isótopos del hidrógeno que existen en el
planeta tierra este sería el peso
promedio los isótopos que son más
comunes son los que van a representar la
mayor parte de este peso atómico y el
peso atómico de sus masas atómicas es
1.200 79 sin embargo para este primer
ejercicio que vamos a hacer vamos a
decir que para facilitarnos los cálculos
la masa atómica del hidrógeno es muy
cercana a 1 una forma de pensar en esto
que no es muy preciso y no es cómo se
definen las cosas aquí es una forma útil
de conceptualizar la masa a nivel
atómico es que un neutrón
un protón
tienen una masa atómica aproximada de
una unidad de masa atómica en otros
vídeos veremos por qué es que no se
define así la unidad de masa atómica y
por qué está basada en el isótopo de
carbono 12 pero esto es una buena
herramienta para ayudarnos a
conceptualizar una aproximación general
de una masa atómica y vimos que el
hidrógeno tiene un protón pero también
tiene una masa atómica de 1 o bueno muy
cercana por lo que debe tener un protón
y ese es el caso de la mayoría de los
átomos de hidrógeno al menos en el
planeta tierra un hidrógeno es un protón
con un electrón y el electrón también
contribuye a la masa del átomo pero es
mínima comparada con la masa de un
protón así que la masa del átomo es
esencialmente la del protón aunque un
poquito del electrón y también el peso
promedio cuando pensamos en todos los
demás isótopos del hidrógeno los cuales
podrían tener por ahí algún neutro pero
para este ejemplo podemos decir que el
hidrógeno es un
con un electrón el cual está saltando
alrededor del protón por lo que es
aproximadamente una unidad de masa
atómica con el oxígeno es la misma idea
vemos la tabla periódica y podemos
adivinar a qué se acerca su masa el
hecho tuvo más común del oxígeno que
encontraremos en la tierra tiene 8
protones lo cual es lo que hace que sea
oxígeno cualquier oxígeno siempre va a
tener 8 protones en cualquier lugar del
universo pero además de tener sus 8
protones va a tener 8 neutrones
este es el isótopo más común del oxígeno
así que pueden adivinar que su masa
atómica es de 16 unidades de masa
atómica la cual es una muy buena
aproximación si vemos el peso atómico
aquí el cual es el peso promedio de los
diferentes isótopos de oxígeno que
encontramos aquí en la tierra
encontramos que es 15.999 redondeada lo
cual es muy cercano a 16 por lo que
nuestra aproximación de 16 es bastante
buena
base en estos números podemos decir que
esté h2o tiene una masa atómica
aproximada de dos de los hidrógenos este
dos viene de la suma de la masa de cada
hidrógeno que aquí son dos hidrógenos 2
por 1 es 2 y 16 del oxígeno 2 16 es 18
unidades de masa atómica si queremos ser
más precisos o si tenemos esta gran
bolsa con agua y no estábamos observando
exactamente una sola molécula de agua
cuál será el promedio de la masa de esas
moléculas de agua pues aquí nos ayudaría
a ser un poco más precisos y esto es
útil sobre todo cuando tenemos una gran
cantidad de moléculas de algún elemento
y queremos considerar el peso promedio
de esas moléculas en estos casos nos es
útil usar el peso atómico por lo que en
el caso del hidrógeno el peso atómico es
1.000 79 unidades de masa atómica y
aunque le llamamos peso atómico
realmente es un promedio de las
masas atómicas y no el peso como lo
conocemos en el sentido físico como una
medida de fuerza
así que 1.000 79 unidades de masa
atómica y en el caso del oxígeno es
15.999 redondeado unidades de masa
atómica si queremos tener un número más
preciso aquí sacamos la calculadora y
voy a tener dos por 1.000 79
que es igual a esto y esto le voy a
agregar 15.999
y este resultado lo voy a redondear a
digamos que tres lugares decimales aquí
no quiero agregar precisión si quieres
saber más sobre esto pueden ver la serie
de vídeos sobre cantidades
significativas si estoy sumando
cantidades que sólo tienen tres
decimales significativos a la derecha
el resultado no debe tener más de tres
así que tenemos 18 puntos 0 1
redondeamos a 5 aquí así que es 18.015
unidades de masa atómica y ustedes
pueden considerar esto como el peso
molecular ya que estamos usando un peso
promedio de la masa atómica y podemos
pensar que el peso promedio de una
molécula de agua será más cercana a esto
sin embargo estos dos números son muy
cercanos así que podemos llamar a esto
peso molecular de cualquier manera estas
ideas están muy relacionadas cuando
estamos en la escala atómica y las
personas usan el término peso no se
están refiriendo a una fuerza como lo
hacemos en la física que están medidas
en youtube
están refiriendo a un peso promedio de
masas por lo que el peso molecular del
agua es 18 puntos 0 15 unidades de masa
atómica y si quieren verse más relajados
pueden decir que es igual a 18 unidades
de masa atómica